Now that we have seen how instruction scheduling works, let's see
how it interacts with things like if conversion. Recall that if
conversion works like this. We had some code and then there
is an if then else, which means there is a branch.
Sometimes we do this, sometimes we do this, and then
we go back to doing something after the if then
else. Let's say this is the orange code and let's
say that this is the green code. Before if conversion,
we can easily reschedule code within here. We can also
move things around within this, we can move things around
within this, and we can move things around within this.
But it's hard to mix the code from these together.
For example, take an instruction from here to
fill a store here. Because if we end up
going this way that instruction doesn't get done, so
it gets a lot more complicated. However after If
conversion we do the stuff that was before the
if then else. We then have the orange code
predicated so that it only results in execution. And
then we have the orange code predicated one way.
Greens are code predicated the other way and then the
stuff after the loop. And, now because this is branch
free code and, because all of these instructions really execute
every time, it's just that they are predicated sometimes. We can
easily take instructions from here and put them here to
avoid stalls. And that's nice. We can even take instructions
from here and put them here or instructions from here
and put them here, for that matter we can even take
instructions from here and put them here. So overall, we get a lot more
opportunities for filling stall cycles with something
useful. So if conversion is one of
those things that. It helps with branch
prediction because you're going branches, and it
also can tremendously help the compiler in
making a better schedule for a processor.